meanwhile the cabinet here discussed the
situation on ukraine's border with
russia today after reports of a russian
troop build up increased concerns about
a possible invasion the prime minister
said that the uk would continue to
support the territorial integrity of
ukraine and also reaffirmed the uk's
opposition to the nordstream 2 pipeline
that would bypass ukraine and would pipe
russian gas directly to the european
union well joining me now is vadim
krishnako ukraine's ambassador to the uk
a very good evening to you mr ambassador
well first of all give us the overview
ukraine's assessment of the situation on
that border the russian troop build-up i
know your foreign minister is describing
a seriously deterior deteriorating
situation we're also hearing of russian
tanks being prepared at rail heads
further back from the border in
preparation
to be being moved there your assessment
please thank you i agree with you there
are two processes
seem to be independent but there is a
plot
behind it first of all the thousands of
people
been found themselves
in landlocked belarus from somewhere
else and knocking at the door of
european union so the question is how
they got there and what sort of pictures
we will see in frozen forests of belarus
next to the poland borders all these
kids everybody else who is now waiting
until being allowed into
and second this process of russia has
been messing the troops around our
border now there are numbers uh
dangerous it's not uh death and life yet
ukrainians can after seven years of war
can put up a real fight but this is
going to be very very dangerous for us
especially these troops which been
armored was the newest russian tanks
from where from moscow region
how they get here and why they stay here
over the over the winter this is a big
question well how serious could it get
then i mean we are talking potentially
are we about another invasion about
armed conflict
unfortunately we can exclude this this
option too we hope that with everybody's
effort we'll be able to de-escalate
that's what your prime minister asked
that's what the secretary general of
nato everybody else did the you know the
cia chief went to moscow to talk to the
leadership directly we hope that after
all these efforts will be able to
de-escalate the problem is that they
state in paul in in belarus which
they're more or less
formally informally occupied already
there is a new additional to russia and
unfortunately we share
1110 kilometers of the border so you see
the the two issues has linked the
situation on belarus and the polish
border is this some a hybrid operation
by russia because of course some that
could be stopped one imagines the
situation in belarus if president putin
wanted it to for sure we've been tried
with green little men as we call them in
in crimea polls now with the immigrants
innocent people being used and played by
by by putin and by luka shanka
so how important is it to ukraine the
support of the european union the
support of the uk uh we know that uh our
defense minister our secretary of state
for defence has been in ukraine today
he's just just finished the
conversations with my president and i
understand that everything we are
discussing right now with you that what
our leaders discussed as well on top of
real steps is not just conversations we
just announced that we signed 1.7
billion defense contract with you so
it's not about
just jobs but both jobs will be created
on both sides in ukraine and here but
we're also talking about real uh
assistance of the great britain to help
ukraine withstand this pressure with
russians 1.7 billion
contracts there is a danger though is
there not that that could further enrage
russia and president putin it's not
enough for us to withstand all
depression but i believe that the
situation is opposite the more prepared
we are to be real strong and stay for
our principles isn't that where all of
us share
so what would you let us explore the the
possibility of a further russian
incursion into ukrainian territory what
response would ukraine expect from nato
countries and those countries within the
european union that aren't members of
nato
as you know we are not member yet we are
knocking at the door for last 30 years
we are not allowed yet in
but i believe that there is time when
our partners we are not always can call
our friends allies but at least partners
with the nato would understand how
dangerous is that it's not
further away as afghanistan is not your
boys are going anywhere but this is
somewhere very close to the doors of
european union what we see right now
with west poland who'd expect that
russia would go with all the force but
they found another way of hybrid way of
of getting ninja and i believe that what
they're doing on poland borders they're
just distracted attention of european
union which creates the opportunity the
window opportunity for them to knock at
our door
but i'm trying to find out would you
have an expectation if substantial
russian forces move across that border
to to grab more ukrainian land would you
expect
an armed response from from nato members
we can expect the ukrainians will fight
to the deaths we hope that some some
response will come not just you know
graveyard sort of
words or even sanctions because we see
the sanctions have not stopped them for
a seven years war but something more
more substantial and we are now within
this contract with contract with the
americans we are receiving real weapons
which will allow us to fight and we
stand immediate pressure we'll buy some
time until world will decide what what
to do with dictator named putin okay but
you hear these words you're hearing
these words from the european union from
the united kingdom from the united
states of course but are you in ukraine
scarred by the experience of the
annexation of crimea by president putin
back in 2014 when we heard the same
denunciations coming from your allies in
the west and in the end president putin
managed that virtually unopposed
i agree with you but somebody at the
time believed that we what we're trying
to avoid we're trying to avoid sorry uh
world war
which we hope the russians would
understand too because they also part of
this society they live with the same
planet but we now see that after seven
years the sanctions good words bad words
didn't stop him from from going further
what is not needed now we believe that's
more more direct approach at means that
somebody and i'm not that much looking
at the european union now rather than
nato will be able to really stand with
us
that is very worrying language a very
worrying phrase expression used there mr
ambassador third world war are you
serious about that i believe the part of
the world was serious about the seven
years ago with us being where they were
now and with the rest of the world been
prepared now i believe that we can avoid
this and what role does the nordstream 2
pipeline just explain to our audience
this is the huge pipeline it's been many
years in construction which in effect
bypasses ukraine would take russian gas
much needed russian gas directly to the
european union it's built it hasn't been
approved and we are told now that that
approval has been suspended you would
see that as a positive move i imagine it
is a good move but uh unfortunately this
isn't rather technical sort of terms it
can they can be playing for some time
but if it is just
technical it won't resolve everything
what i'm here to say that ukrainian
pipeline could provide european union
all the european nations with the gas
easily we have enough capacity for the
for the russians are doing this it's
just rather weaponizing the gas but do
you think this is the play by russia to
get that pipeline approved and then
perhaps they'd they'd back off obviously
they will use this gas they won't use
ukrainian pipeline with which will untie
their hands in ukraine in ukrainian
campaign which is yet another risk in in
really military invasion are you worried
about the german attitude to to this i
mean the pipeline in the main we'll
we'll start supplying germany uh we hear
that um outgoing chancellor angela
merkel
has continuing uh decent relations let's
say that with the kremlin and that in
actual fact has
overridden president biden in his
opposition to north stream too i i am
worrying because the germans were not
understanding of for all these years and
years they tried it before i remember
the predecessor of mother merkel who
promised to help us with that but then
became a deputy chief of gas promise
himself so when we are talking about
germans
we have to understand how closely they
connected economically to russians and
how much in their calculations of what
is going on in their in neighborhood is
depends on the actually on the russian
gas or some some else from the russian
federation and we hear that chancellor
merkel has also been speaking to um
president's uh well uh illegal president
telugu
in belarus do you think that's a wise
idea to engage with that regime
she's a great leader i don't suspect
that she's naive but when she's asking
putin to influence lukashenko not to do
this this is naivety
and what is the mood amongst the people
of ukraine at the moment
i mean is there is there fear on the
streets
not that much people get quite
accustomed which is bad again after
seven years of war and 13 000 people
killed so people get used to listen to
the tv like yours and find out that yet
another soldier been killed today which
is not great but people can withstand
this pressure at least what putin is
trying to do we are not changing our
foreign policy courses you may see we're
still going to european union and nato
we're still trying to
introduce the same values you have here
and would you say that the uk is taking
a stronger line than for instance
germany in supporting ukraine
particularly the words we heard last
night we've heard them again today from
the prime minister about nordstrom 2 and
about the integrity of ukrainian
territory look after in the four days
you have your minister of foreign
affairs your prime minister your chief
of defense
speaking about this openly in the
parliament we have your secretary of
state for defense coming to ukraine just
in four days we have this contract one
point said biggest i don't know when was
the biggest contract been signed here on
defense all of the things together this
is something which i don't even have as
a foreign ambassador to give a hint to
tell you that yes you you united kingdom
is doing much more than many many others
i can put in this here in the line maybe
maybe americans that's more or less the
core of the group which is supporting i
don't want to to downplay the europeans
efforts with that without the help
assistance financials is we won't be
able to to put up this fight but if
you're talking about real actions this
is two major partners where we can
depend right now and just uh finally
we're nearly out of time mr ambassador
give me your assessment then your
assessment of just how dangerous the
situation is because russia has built up
forces on your border before and it's
been building up these forces since at
least the spring
your assessment then of how likely any
conflict is
200 kilometers from us two three days
maximum for the tanks that's how close
the injury is
and that's all we know so far mr
ambassador thank you very much steve for
coming in to talk to us on sky news
tonight uh vadim